the cool thing about youtube
is it might not go for a while but like
10 years later right yeah it'll be
like this the thing this what people
don't understand with youtube at least
for now
at least that's my hope with it is uh
it's a leg it's a it's literally better
than publishing a book in terms of the
legacy
it's it will live for a long long time
of course it's uh one of the things i
mentioned joe rogan before it's kind of
there's a sad thing because i'm a fan
he's moving to spotify yeah
yeah nine digit numbers will do that to
you yeah but he doesn't really
that he's one a person that doesn't
actually care that much about money
like having talked to him he it it
wasn't because of money
it's because he legitimately thinks that
they're go going to do like
a better job like so they're so from his
perspective youtube you have to
understand where they're coming from
youtube has been cracking down on
people who they you know joe rogan talks
to alex jones and conspiracy theories
and youtube was really like careful that
kind of stuff
and that's not a good feeling like and
joe didn't
doesn't feel like youtube was on his
side um you know he's often has
videos that they don't put in trending
that like
are obviously should be in trending
because they're nervous
about like you know if this concept is
this
is this content uh going to you know
upset people
that all that kind of stuff have
misinformation and that's not a good
place for a person
to be in and spotify is giving them uh
we're never going to censor you
we're never going to do that but the
reason i bring that up
whatever you think about that i
personally think that's because
podcasting should be free and not
constrained to a platform it's pirate
radio what the hell
you can't as much as i love spotify you
can't just
you can't put fences around it
but uh anyway the reason i bring that up
is uh joe's gonna remove his entire
library from youtube
whoa really that's going to his full
length the clips are going to stay but
the full length videos
are all i mean made private or deleted
that's part of the deal and like that's
the first time where i was like
oh youtube videos might not live forever
like things you find
like okay sorry this is why you need um
ipfs or something where it's like if
there's a content link
are familiar with this system at all
like right now if you have a url that
points to a server
there's like a system where the address
points to content and then it's like
distributed
so you you can't actually delete what's
at an address because it's
it's content addressed and as long as
there's someone on the network who hosts
it
it's always accessible at the address
that it once was um
but i mean that raises a question i'm
not gonna
put you on the spot but like somebody
like vsauce right
spotify comes along and gives him let's
say
100 billion dollars okay let's say some
crazy number
and then removes it from youtube right
it's
maybe i don't know
for some reason i thought youtube is
forever i don't think it will be i mean
you know another variant that this might
take is like uh that
you know um you fast forward 50 years
and
uh you know google or alphabet isn't the
company that it once was and it's kind
of struggling to make ends meet
and you know it's been supplanted by the
whoever wins on the ar game or whatever
it might be
and then they're like you know all of
these videos that we're hosting are
pretty costly
so we're just we're going to start
deleting the ones that aren't watched
that much and
tell people to like try to back them up
on their own or whatever it is
um or even if it does exist in some form
forever it's like if people are
um not habituated to watching youtube in
50 years they're watching something else
which seems pretty likely
like it would be shocking if youtube
remained as popular as it is now
indefinitely into the future that's true
so uh
it won't be forever it makes me sad
still but
because it's such a nice it's like just
like you said
of the canonical videos sorry i don't
interrupt you know
you should get juan bennett on the uh on
the thing and then talk to him about
permanence
i think he would have a good
conversation who's that so he's the one
that founded this thing called ipfs that
i'm
talking about and if if you have him
talk about basically what you're
describing like oh it's sad that this
isn't forever
then you'll get some articulate
quantification around it
yeah that's like been pretty well
thought through uh but yeah i do see
youtube just like you said
as a as a place like what your channel
creates which is like
a set of canonical videos on a topic now
others could create
videos on that topic as well but as a
collection it creates
a nice set of places to go uh if you're
curious about a particular topic
and it seems like coronavirus is a nice
opportunity to
put that knowledge out there in the
world at
mit and beyond
you